[Music]
today I want to talk about the different
versions of wire you can buy we run
typically all the time ten thousands
brass wire
we buy a specific kind of medium grade
zinc coated wire
at a certain price point and we do
pocket inserts like if you see right
here what we're looking at we make a lot
of
inserts that go into molds for either
logos or
labeling of some kind on the tool
and what I want to talk about is you can
buy just a straight brass this is a
straight brass wire
for a certain price you can buy a zinc
coated wire for another price or you can
buy a very high end
um zinc coated premium wire which has
the ability to
lower the feed of the wire through the
machine which allows you to cut more and
it can also increase the speed so the
main thing about wire EDM is the ability
to go fast everyone wants to go faster
because if you can get more out of the
spool you can get more out during the
day which means you can make make more
more money in the company doing it that
way but the challenge that we find is
there's a huge price difference from
some of these wire spools this premium
one I'm testing it right now it's 258
dollars the one that we normally run
with the cost of everything going up
brass has been affected and it the one I
normally run went from like 135 now it's
185 and I'm trying to see how I can make
these brass wires make sense for me in
my shop and I'm curious what people run
um in other shops that some of the
high-end wire isn't going to make sense
for for some shops but it makes a ton of
sense for some shops that are running a
ton of one part and with Optimum flush
and we're going to try to get into some
of those settings and and I'm actually
going to run some test Cuts so we can
kind of compare what what will be
um the most beneficial for for your shop
and for ours
one question I want to ask everyone is
is it more important to save costs on
The Wire just the wire itself or is it
more important to save the cost and the
Machine time and the run time that's a
very challenging question and it's
really difficult to answer because you
can buy more expensive wire and get more
through the machine less wear
or much less expensive wire it's and it
takes longer and some people don't care
how long it takes and others they only
have one machine like we do and we need
to get as much through it as possible so
that's a good question to ask
here we have our three brass wires we
got
straight brass zinc coated
zinc coated premium wire
big difference in costs we're going to
attempt to wire through this block
um and do a study on how fast we can go
how long it takes and how well it burns
first thing I'm going to do here is set
up a this block in the fast hole machine
to put our start holes in as you can see
we're going to need to put a bunch of
holes in in order to get our wire to
feed through those holes and make our 3
8 diameter
hole that we're looking to put in there
those are actually going to be like
ejector pinholes
and to represent like an injection mold
so here we go
when we fast hold we want to make sure
that that
Rod is as short as it can go
and then we bring the head down as close
as we can go
this bet this is best for flush
[Music]
number two
to make a straight comparison of the
wire we're going to you start off with
the standard settings from our MV 2400r
and we are going to use the standard
setup that is recommended and it's in
increments of quarter inch thickness and
in between the thicknesses is where our
block lies at one inch 875 so we're
going to go with this the slightly
oversized eighth inch over
the 1h75s with two inch settings and try
to make this as Fair as we can with no
modifications to the settings or the
machine
we're here with Dan we're getting ready
to run our first hole with the height
the premium
zinc coated wire on our first hole we're
going to do a pocketed routine
you can see on the screen
we're going to do a pocketing quarter
inch hole which is going to do a rough
and a finish with three skims
as our first comparison
one thing I wanted to point out is
we have a good plush condition so we're
turning the power Master off
power Masters use when there's a poor
flushing condition or changing Z depths
in the burn
so just for Apples to Apples comparison
we're going to have the power Master off
for this good flushing condition and
also the e-adjust is really the only
things that we're going to be messing
with
um at all we're not even going to mess
with it's going to be right in the
middle for these three different wires
for these three test burns with the
premium wire
here's our pin
it's a good fit
and we're going to start the next hole
with a different wire switch to the zinc
coated wire I want to give you the time
on this one which is the premium wire 42
minutes 33 seconds
all right this is hole number two it
started we'll see how long it takes all
right second hole just finished it's
about it's about one minute
different so from the premium zinc to
just the zinc
only about a minute so far so we're
gonna try just the regular brass at this
point it's loaded we're gonna start that
one right now
this is the last one this is just the
brass wire we just did similar fits on
all three holes but here's the times
straight brass ran 46 minutes
54 seconds
zinc coated
middle of the road brass or Brash was 43
minutes 22 seconds and the high end wire
was 42 minutes and 33 seconds
so
in conclusion the wire the brass wire
runs slowest
it runs about 165 a spool of 22 pounds
the
zinc coated wires for 185
and that's 22 pounds and that ran
couple minutes faster and I'll show you
a chart in just a second and then the
high-end brass was only less than a
minute difference in this particular
burn remember it's just a straight
good flushing condition with the three
different wires just to do a apples
apples comparison
the one thing that we're going to do now
is we're going to change some settings
on the machine to utilize the technology
of the high end wire we should be able
to slow it down from six feed rate wire
feed to or I'm sorry from eight to six
on the wire feed and then actually move
the the E condition setting on the
control up three notches as well so
we're going to try to go a little bit
faster and use use this technology
as much as we can
finished the second test of the high end
wire
it did work
except we noticed that we could slow the
feed of the wire itself from eight to
six which means it uses a lot less wire
to do the same thing and that was that
was only on the roughs so on the skims
it kicks the speed back up to get the
correct skins
but we did notice that it actually took
almost a minute more
which is surprising but it used less
wire so
it's not it's not it's a lot faster like
I thought it would
so we'll we'll uh
kind of come to a conclusion on what's
good for our shop as we look at the
results
let's talk about the results that we got
from our test Burns but we started off
with this we'll start with a brass
straight brass wire it took 46 minutes
54 seconds
a rough and three skims on a cordhole a
250 diameter
on a block that was an inch 875 thick
um
the next wire we used was the zinc
coated wire the SL wire and here's the
prices so we go 165 for 22 pounds we're
at 185 and now we're at 258 dollars for
the specific wire I got we got it from
Belmont
and they've been super helpful with
their knowledge base and the information
they have
but we're looking at what we've actually
done in our shop
and what I'm trying to understand is is
it worth for us
to utilize this expensive wire the
medium wire or the straight brass wear
so it looks like I can pick up a you
know roughly three three minutes just
moving let's say a 20 difference in in
the wire itself with the zinc coated I
can go a little bit faster
and that's really what we're after at
our shop we have one wire EDM machine
here so it makes sense for us to try to
squeeze as much time as we can out of it
so for twenty dollars if I can get more
time
that makes sense but I can't see
spending almost a hundred dollars more
per spool to not gain that much time
um
this high-end wire does some very cool
things we've seen it go through pits and
bad conditions through Weld and uh just
bad porosity and some steel
so there is a benefit to this type of
wire but in the most cases for what we
do we're working with good materials we
really haven't had a big need for it but
one thing that was very cool and it does
make sense is that you can slow the wire
feed down from eight to six and increase
the E adjust on our Mitsubishi
and that actually it actually helps use
less wire less wear in my rollers and
all the bearings so there's an entire
maintenance factor for something like if
you were running production
um same Parts over and over or large
Pockets or inserts that wire does
justify the cost at that point but in
most cases for us we're going to stick
with the with the SL wire the string the
zinc coated
it's a little bit more money than the
straight brass but it does go faster and
having the one machine makes sense for
us another huge Factor about the wire is
when we set it up and we run it we want
to be able to make a program in a spree
set it up on the machine and and walk
away from it that it's going to run and
be Dependable it's going to be
consistent we're going to get the whole
sizes that we wanted the insert sizes
that we want
so having to go in there and adjust
settings on all the different things
that we do and the different thicknesses
that would be a very big time consumer
which ends up costing us money and time
so
um one of the big things that to
consider when sourcing wire and I do
recommend getting with your supplier if
it's Belmont or whoever that you find
out what your needs are exactly and see
if they have something that will fit
your needs but for us being being able
to walk away from it getting to
predictable results are always the top
things that we're looking for another
key feature to the wire EDM is that we
recycle all of the wire so we do get
some of the money recovered back it's
obviously not near the amount that you
pay for the school but it's not a total
waste there is a recovery of that
material as long as you're recycling it
definitely not gold but it is valuable
that you you'd want to take advantage of
that thanks for joining us for our
episode of learn to burn
uh please remember to subscribe and like
we hope that our content has been
helpful
um if you do have questions remember to
put them in the comments and we will see
you next month
joining us for our episode dang come on
out of it then it makes it makes it
let's talk about these this these
results after we restart this one
I'm not sure what to say discuss the
topic of different brands or different
foreign
this is going to be a bluebird